so you have critics
uh
uh I would love you to take it seriously
and sort of consider this criticism and
trying to steal me in their their case
uh there's a bunch uh I could mention uh
this this list of criticisms from Bob
ward in London School of Economics I
don't know if you're familiar with him
but just on this point in terms of one
of the big costs being an energy
he criticizes your recent book in saying
you consider the 143 billion in annual
support for renewable energy but ignore
the 300 billion in fossil fuel subsidies
so a lot of the criticism has to do
with well you're cherry picking the
models which the models are always
cherry picking and you anyway
um but you know you want to take those
seriously so uh he claims that you
ignore
you're not uh fully modeling the costs
the the trade-off here how expensive is
the renewable energy and how expensive
is the fossil fuel can you still mana's
case sure so uh two things uh the first
the quote it's it's absolutely true that
the world spends a large a chunk of
money on fossil fuels and that's just
stupid and we should stop doing it we
should also recognize that this is not
rich countries this is not the countries
where we're talking about climate change
this is poor countries this is Saudi
Arabia uh no that actually not a
terribly poor country uh it's China it's
Indonesia it's uh uh Russia uh it's
places where you're basically paying off
your population just like that you
subsidized bread you make sure that they
don't rebel by making cheap uh fuels
available that's dumb but it's not like
they you know they don't know what
they're doing they're mostly doing this
for things that have nothing to do with
climate so I totally agree we should get
rid of it it's hard to do Indonesia is
actually somewhat uh managed to to get
rid of it because remember if you spend
a lot of money on fossil fuel subsidies
you're basically subsidizing the rich
because you know poor people don't have
a car it's the rich people who can now
buy you know a very cheap gasoline
that's you know that's unjust as well so
it's dumb in so many different ways I
would never argue that you shouldn't
done I plenty of time said we should
stop that but we should also recognize
these are mostly regimes that are not
going to be taken over either by my
argument or Bob Wards or anyone else's
they're doing this for totally different
reasons now on the model side
there is virtually no model that don't
show economic model that don't show this
has a cost and that's the fundamental
point is that the you know this is sort
of a basic point from from economics the
system is already working most
effectively because if it wasn't you
know you could actually make money
changing over so if you want to have a
change outside of what the system is
already doing it's because you're saying
you have to do something that you rather
not want to do namely use an energy
source that is less convenient or less
cost effective and so on and that will
incur a cost now there's a huge
discussion about just exactly how much
cost is that so there's definitely a
cost is the cost going to be one or five
trillion that's absolutely a discussion
about where do you take your models from
I try to do and and again this is not
possible everywhere I try to actually
take the average of all of the economic
models so there's a there's a group
called the Stanford energy modeling
Forum which tries to pull together all
these different groups that do the
modeling so some models a lot of this
cost actually comes down to uh uh the
fact that we don't quite know how much
more fossil fuels you're going to need
in the future and so if you're not gonna
if your projections are you're not going
to use that much the cost of reducing it
is going to be very small if you think
you're going to use a ton of extra
fossil fuels and you have to reduce that
the cost is going to be bigger so I
think that's just one of the variables
that's oh yeah yeah and there's many
many many more I think the the point
here is to say that if you take the
average of all the best model is a sort
of aggregated for instance at the
Stanford energy modeling form you're
pretty secure ground
and and uh so so again I I would argue
that Bob Ward yes I've had a lot of
run-ins with Bob board uh uh and and he
has very different uh set of views on on
things uh but but I I just don't think
he's right in saying that I'm cherry
picking well yes and I mean he also has
similar criticism about the estimate of
the EU cost of climate action uh based
on the knob 2013 model But ultimately
these criticism had to do is like what
are the sources for the different models
and and just very briefly I mean I'm I'm
laying it out very transparently where I
get these models of where I get these
estimates from in the book I've really
tried to document this and yes I mean
look there's nobody who sort of has all
the information and gets everything
right in all of these areas uh I I think
most of uh uh but Ward's uh argument is
is not a uh a good faith effort to uh to
sort of uh improve on on these estimates
he's he's right and saying some of these
estimates we only have a few estimates
and you know yeah I'd like to have more
of them I one thing I should mention is
that there is very little interest in
general and there's very little funding
in finding out how much do our climate
policies cost because that's you know
that's just inconvenient to everyone
yeah in in the whole game you know who
wants to know that that you know for
instance uh uh would would you want to
fund uh something that says that the
inflation reduction Act is not going to
be very effective of course you don't
want to do that right so so it's again
it's a little bit the you know flock of
birds it will look some at something
else and and what I think is that given
that we're paying for it again this is
you know this is public money we're
deciding we're going to spend money here
rather than there let's at least you
know look at what are the best estimates
out there I would love to be have more
estimates uh more estimates is always
better and just a quick comment on the
good faith part me as a consumer looking
for truth it's hard to find who's good
faith and not so it's not only are you
looking for
a sort of accurate information
you're also trying to infer about the
communicator of that information that's
very difficult it's uh you know you put
me on the on the podcast of course I'm
gonna say I'm a trustworthy guy but yeah
I mean but and we believe we're
trustworthy too but
um you know I've been reading for
various reasons but mostly because I've
been traveling to Ukraine and thinking
and just about the people's
um suffering through war I've been
reading a lot about World War II and and
Stalin and Hitler and you know from the
perspective of Hitler
uh he really believed he's doing good
for the world and he was
communicating from his perspective in
good faith
um he started to believe I think early
on his own propaganda so you're even
your understanding and perception of the
world completely shifted so it's it's
very very very difficult to understand
who to trust
um
and uh just because it's a consensus in
a particular Community doesn't
necessarily mean it's a source of trust
so it's a I mean basically
I don't know how to operate in this
world except to have a humility and
constantly question your assumptions and
but not so much that you're completely
out in the ocean not knowing what is
true or not so it's this weird weird
world because I I ultimately bigger than
climate
my hope is to have institutions that can
be trusted
and that's been very much under attack
um in as as part of the climate debate
as part of the covid debate as part of
all these discussions and science to me
is one of the sources
of truth and the fact that that's under
question now is uh something that hurts
me on many levels uh deeply you said
something earlier as I took a note down
down here and I can't find it about
cooperation it was like collaborative
cooperation or something like that sure
what to me there was a point like in
2013
after just dealing with all everything
you've been grappling with
what if you don't if you know you don't
know how this is going to work out what
do you work on
and I one morning I made a list of words
that kind of summarized
basically system properties that give
you confidence in a system trust or and
their transparency is one
just as you were saying earlier
um
connectivity is another you know so
everyone's connected
so on the subsidy issue for example
they're young entrepreneurs in Nairobi
who are selling ingeniously using
nairobi's digital currency
uh propane the fuel that's in our
backyard barbecue grills which comes out
of gas Wells but it's a separate fuel
in little increments that poor people
can use instead of charcoal
and LPG subsidies are helping them
get people off of charcoal which is a
horrific trade from The Source through
the Warlords in Somalia and elsewhere
who are getting the money to the
pollution in houses
so so having
be sure being sure when we're having
these big debates about who the World
Bank is going to give loans to and
drawing a simple line no more fossil
fuel subsidies
hurts a really good valuable
small scale but scalable way to have
people not die from cooking smoke in
their houses and and take down for us so
but that only is considered if they're
in the conversation so connectivity full
connectivity digital access so so those
entrepreneurs are in the mix of people
when they're thinking about subsidies
you're not just thinking about big bad
Exon you're thinking about this little
company in Nairobi Pago Pago LPG I think
is the name and India the same thing so
so you can list those properties of
systems
and the ipcc wasn't originally
transparent
when I started writing about it in 1988
and 1990 and now it's way more
transparent they have more public review
so it's even better than it was it's
like a really good example of a science
process of assessing the science
providing periodic output to the world
and iteratively improving the model
going forward because of critique
because because of you know scrutiny and
finding better ways for that to
interface with people so they have
information they can use from that big
thing and the media you know are not
doing a good job
um because of this front page thoughtism
um but we can all you know I work
partially in Academia Colombia on an
initial initiative partially in
communication Innovation like how can we
have an open landscape of access to
information that matters how can you
what can you do to Foster better
conversations so that words like
collapse aren't just thrown around like
emblems and and so system properties
give you confidence I think and then you
then you don't have to like be flailing
around for Bjorn or Tom Tom Friedman or
Catherine hayhot you can always right
now find your you're you're your
character to follow but I think what
would be better is if you actually
develop some skills to just have a basic
ability
to know how to cut to the chase
can I can I just follow up on that
because one of the things that I try to
do and and so my day job is actually
something else I work with I think thing
called The Copenhagen consensus uh where
we work with uh more than 300 of the
world's top economists and we work with
seven noble Lawrence and economics and
and the point there is really to talk
about where can you spend a dollar and
do the most good for the world that's
that's basically the the thing that we
try to do and and as as you rightly
point out look there are lots of
different estimates of what can you do
for instance on climate what can you do
on tuberculosis what can you do for uh
vulnerability in all kinds of different
different ways and and if these were all
sort of well you can spend a dollar here
and do 2.36 but you can spend it all
here and do 2.34 over here that I would
worry a lot but that's not how the world
works because we're terribly inefficient
so they're literally lots and lots of
amazing things you can do out there
there's a lot of little hanging fruit
and there's a lot of not terribly great
things that you can do and unfortunately
one of the things I try to sort of
battle is that you know we get a lot of
things right that's why you know the
world is a lot better than what it used
to be uh but the things that are sort of
left left over are often you know the
boring things that happen to be
incredibly effective and the exciting
things that are often not that terribly
effective uh and and so I think one way
to look at this is basically to have
people do cost benefit across a wide
range of areas and we try to get a lot
of different economists to do this and
they come up with different numbers and
different models and different results
but if you sort of consistently get that
some things give you you know in tens or
maybe even hundreds of dollars back per
dollar remember this is not actually you
getting rich it's the world getting rich
it's that the world gets better worth a
hundred dollars for for every dollar you
spend and over here you can spend a
dollar and do somewhere between 30 cents
and maybe a couple dollars you should
probably be focused on the other
opportunity first and that's really the
point that I try to make with climate
there are some smart things we can do
and I hope we get to talk about them uh
in in climate but there's also a lot of
sort of the standard approaches to
fixing climate
turns out to be very likely below one
dollars back in dollar and certainly not
terribly High you know even if you're
very optimistic it'll be like two or
three whereas many other things are just
fantastically better investment like the
thing I've been advocating uh a modest
proposal to eat the children of the poor
in England was that the in Jonathan
Swift Modest Proposal from a few
centuries ago
um so it's not just cause benefit it's
also in the context of what is moral and
not and all that the full the full
complexity of it but that you just hit
on something really important you know
having been on this beat for so long and
again on the disaster beat as well
earthquakes
I can't tell you how many disaster
science experts keep telling me like
everyone says preparedness invest for
preparedness a strict cost-benefit
analysis will always tell you a dollar
invested in resilience before Community
gets hit by whatever
is worth 10 you'll always have to spend
10 after and so it's fine to do the cost
benefit stuff but it's just the Baseline
then you have to look at the social
science which shows or history which
shows you how few times we do it it's
like we just don't do it therefore you
can bang that drum your work is valuable
but it's really constrained because show
me in the world
where that does happen and then how you
turn that success which is basically
something not happening into the story
just very briefly you know we we try to
so we we do this for a lot of countries
so we did it for uh Haiti for instance
uh uh funded by the Canadian development
uh Ministry because they're basically
saying we spent a billion dollars in
Haiti since the earthquake and we really
can't tell the difference so they want
it to find they I mean they actually say
that right and so they said we want to
find out what are the really smart
things you can do in Haiti and so we we
uh together with lots of you know uh
people in Haiti and all the you know the
business community and the political
community and the religious community
and labor community and everybody else
what are the smart things to do and then
we had economists evaluate it and there
are a lot of these things that everybody
wanted that we're not all that smart
there's actually a lot of smart things
and yes the politicians didn't pick most
of them so our our senses we try to give
people uh you know you're thinking about
these 70 things
you should actually just think about
these 20 things right and then we
consider ourselves incredibly lucky if
they actually do one of them